on Tuesday night President Trump
delivers his first State of the Union
address it comes amid an increasingly
bitter fight over immigration reform the
Muller probe and a majority of the
American public holding an unfavorable
view of his presidency for a preview of
what we might hear we are joined by
Michael Waldman he is of course the
president of the Brennan Center for
Justice at NYU and the former director
of speechwriting for President Bill
Clinton he wrote or edited for State of
the Union address that's good morning
Michael
good morning those addresses are long
rodent writing and editing them but
Michael from a president who is
notoriously unpredictable who favors
braggadocio and bluster what do you
expect the tones gonna be on Tuesday
night well there's a kind of tone that
presents generally try to strive for in
a State of the Union they want it to be
a moment where they can command the full
power and majesty as it were of the
office and majesty of the office is not
a phrase one typically associates with
Donald Trump if you think about it
what's complicated with him is we as
listeners we as voters know that
sometimes he can read a speech from a
teleprompter and last year he gave an
address to Congress and it was kind of
boring and and people a lot of people
sort of breathed a sigh of relief but
teleprompter Trump is so different from
Twitter Trump who sounds not like a
regular old president but like someone
calling in to a talk radio show and so
and he often will undermine a big speech
like this just within days by by doing
something which he did last year two or
three days after that speech that
received pretty good marks from people
he at 7:00 in the morning on a Saturday
which to many of us is an early time on
a Saturday I know I know but he tweeted
out that President Obama had had his
phones tapped and we were off to the
races again so yeah I would expect him
to have a sober speech but with a
question mark of how seriously he takes
it or how long it'll last as we
mentioned you wrote many of President
Bill Clinton State of the Union
addresses including those when there was
a cloud of impeachment hanging over him
we've got the Muller investigation
over the president so how how do you
handle that if you're a speech writer
you know different presidents at
different times have addressed scandals
or crises different ways where Richard
Nixon when he was president talked about
Watergate and said one year of Watergate
is enough in Bill Clinton's case he
wanted to just talk about the issues as
he saw them though it was the day before
the the State of the Union in 1998 that
he issued his famous or infamous denial
about Monica Lewinsky I cannot imagine
that President Trump is going to talk
about this I really wish that he would
talk about Russia and foreign
interference in our elections and the
need to protect our democracy in 2018
that's how I think a president ought to
talk about this as we know he tends to
talk about it as fake news and that sort
of stuff and rather than then addressing
it that way
one thing that the president is likely
to address is immigration we are in the
middle of a big fight over the fate of
the dreamers Stephen Miller is going to
be the speech writer on top for the
State of the Union he is notoriously
conservative as it comes to immigration
does that translate to president Trump's
rhetoric on the subject you know it may
well the State of the Union address last
year the address to Congress evidently
had the hand of Gary Cohen who's the
economic adviser from Goldman Sachs the
inaugural address which talked about
American carnage was by all accounts
Steve Bannon and Stephen Miller and
Miller is one of the most sharply
focused on restricting not just illegal
immigration but legal immigration of
anybody in the whole federal government
and it is an interesting moment because
this isn't always the case of these
speeches happen in an interesting time
but there's a big tense negotiation
happening sort of in public over
immigration and the White House is
putting out its proposal which we assume
the president will talk about which is
to legalize up to 1.8 million
dreamers undocumented but but also
demanding 25 billion dollars for the
wall that Mexico
was supposed to pay for it's like he
could be like reading a hostage no
television well we know that the
president's words have had an effect on
the debate before we will see what
happens on Tuesday night Michael Waldman
I know you'll be watching thanks for
your time thank you